[Musique]
tenir une petite main c'est le rêve de
marcia mais pour cette jeune portugaise
avoir un enfant de manière classique est
impossible elle est homosexuel et
célibataire alors à 34 ans elle a décidé
de faire un bébé toute seule
bonjour bonjour quelle est la date de
vos dernières règles c'était le 21
octobre dans cette clinique de lisbonne
elle suit un processus de paix m à une
procréation médicalement assistée dans
deux mois si tout va bien un de ses
ovules sera féconder avec le sperme d'un
inconnu
non ce n'est pas une chose douloureuse
ni impossible à faire mais c'est
fatigant
martial on est pas à sa première
tentative en 2014 elle a déjà fait deux
ans amy nation artificielle son succès
ce n'était pas au portugal car interdit
à ce moment là mais en espagne
voilà ce qu'il me reste des documents et
papiers de mes premières tentatives en
espagne ce sont des analyses et examens
médicaux que j'ai joint à mon dossier
ici au portugal
notre message à témouchent depuis une
loi a été votée dans son pays
en 2016 elle ouvre la pma aux couples
lesbiens et aux femmes seules
désormais les portugaises comme marcia
non plus à payer les allers retours à
l'étranger elles ont le choix de
gratuité en hôpital public et d'autres
avantages au portugal elles ont la
famille et les proches c'est beaucoup
plus facile même en question de travail
le support social et national la famille
des amis et très très très important
dans ces situations si les démarches
sont plus simples elles ne sont pas plus
rapide pour autant marcia elle ne
pouvait plus attendre
elle a préféré payer une clinique privée
même si l'aventuré espagnole lui a déjà
coûté 12 mille euros ont essayé de le
faire dans le public à l'hôpital où
c'est moins lourd financièrement mais il
ya une longue liste d'attentes et oui
c'est un gros effort financier car une
fiv c'est dans les 5000 euros
[Musique]
comment est-ce que vous traduire y est
cela en portugais dans sa vie
quotidienne
marcia assume son choix bonjour au
collège où elle enseigne sa démarche est
plutôt bien vu chacun a le droit de
faire ce qu'il veut pour son projet de
vie je suis maman et je comprends très
bien le désir de marcia je la soutiens à
100%
voilà je crois vraiment que c'est une
non question cette question du pourquoi
elle veut être maire c'est tout
être mère à tout prix pour ce professeur
de bioéthique en ouvrant la pma tout au
portugal on a fait passer le droit
d'avoir des enfants avant celui des
enfants eux mêmes
en d'autres termes on a oublié la
question de la filiation suffit de leur
demander
écoutez vous voulez avoir le droit pas
le droit de pouvoir savoir votre
histoire
tout le monde dit oui je veux avoir le
droit si je vais écrire c'est le droit
ça je ferai mais je veux savoir qu'ils
font mais mes frères qui sont mes demi
soeur qui a été le mieux ou la femme qui
m'a donné sur le sperme ont eux aussi
avoir le droit
si on ne donne pas le droit aux enfants
adolescents jeunes adultes
c'est une violence énorme c'est la
détresse au portugal le don de sperme
est anonyme et une mère célibataire peut
aussi recevoir l'ovocyte d'une autre
femme
c'est cette cuisine du matériel
génétique qui au moment de la discussion
de la loi a fait le plus débat
étonnant dans un des pays les plus
catholiques en europe où les questions
de la famille les questions morales sont
finalement passés au second plan
pour ce député du bloc de gauche qui a
porté la loi
ici c'est une tradition on fait passer
les libertés individuelles avant le
reste c'est juste ça c'est une décision
personnelle pour ces femmes et l'état
n'a pas à interdire de décision
personnelle qui n'ont aucun impact
négatif sur la société
l'idée c'est juste de permettre à ces
personnes de réaliser leur rêve qu'elles
soient les plus heureuse possible
réaliser son rêve s'offrir un enfant
dans son propre pays
le portugal a ouvert les vannes outre la
pma l'adoption et la gpa dans certains
cas ont aussi été autorisés au pays du
fado
on voit cela comme une avancée et on a
du mal à imaginer ce qui en france fait
débat et qui oblige ces femmes à
traverser les frontières
[Musique]